[Music]
what up citizens of the reject Nation it
is time for Scott Pilgrim we are going
to watch episode five and six today John
you good I'm so good G how are you
dude leave a like on this video guys
that would be very much appreciated also
be sure to subscribe and click that
notification notifi when our reaction
with the last two episodes are up here
on the Chanel big thank you to prepper
for helping us edit down these
highlights and lastly massive thank to
all of you who have become super sex Ser
X by joining our patreon page that's
where you can catch the full length
rtion watch along where you sync up with
your own copy of Scott Pilgrim takes off
we also cover several things over there
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included let's see what this next
to are all
about the following documentary began as
a behind the-scenes it's Weird Al the
release of the major Canadian Motion
Picture Scott Pilgrim's precious little
life you caught that voice fast during
the process the movie fall apart this
footage now stands as a firsthand
account of how the movie making dream
can become become what a
nightmare okay death and death inside
the Dream Factory is it true neither of
you have acted before yes but we're very
very famous and that's basically the
same thing
truth I knew you
will have a Punisher shirt on though
world looks like it and now instead of
Brie Larson singing it it's the crowd
singing it we're rock stars we do what
we want and what we want right now is to
be movie
[Laughter]
stars lights camera Sparks uhoh Sparks
Nicholas Sparks people keep asking me if
the movie lives up to my vision I guess
cronenburg for president that Canadian
Cinema love my mom says I should get m
check we're just trying to honor Mr
Neil's tremendous script which I think
is truly a tribute to this great City
say Tonto is a character in the
movie sounds so much like Kevin McDonald
aren't we supposed to be interviewing
Envy Adam stunt double
now does she oh I'm Ramona Flowers they
said I should come talk to you her hair
is blending in with the green screen
uhoh you're the stunt double for Ramona
Flowers and your name is also Ramona
Flowers mhm meta oh she's full of [__]
Ramona
huh when you're done up there I've got
another stunt for you was this just to
get close to Envy I need you to run over
to my hotel room and give my dog some
medication it'll be in a blue bag on the
counter like all good stunt doubles
she's also your assistant I only took
this job because security realized I
wasn't working on the movie and I needed
an excuse to be on set so I could get
close enough to Todd to find out if he
used a vegan portal the Todd no stunts
today I just wanted to ask Todd you're
not wanted here Ramona we're acting okay
so skate on wow what a symbolic shot
that documentary you gotten your classes
huh yeah I finally got a prescription
there sunglasses
H oh
wow I was
wondering from heckling on the sidelines
to lead in a major Canadian Blockbuster
I decided the only thing better than
being me was getting paid to be me true
that influencer why don't we try having
Scott gently put his hand on Ramona's
back oh
sheeps all right Todd just a gentle
little
touch do it
again
wowe action
oh my God this is an adult
film Scott Pilgrim takes it off3
43 put Wallace in between
them oh I go wrong together since we
were 11 years old every day more magical
than the last how was she when she did
Scott maybe we just need to rethink the
scene this is the dumb version but what
if SC and Wallace let's look at each
other deep into each other's eyes You'
never seen eyes like these in your life
oh what's what's about to happen
yes no kiss kiss
I
yes
yes oh my God
no damn get them tongues going
what am I
oh a bisexual vegan would you do us a
huge favor and give us to Envy Adams we
wrote a song for her to sing at the
movie She embarrassing between the last
number and all that jazz and the first
number in gree 2 yes Greece 2 love what
just happened Sparks not sure want to
run lines in your trailer do
I
love
making animation of the movement great
about script run lines in your
trailer nice lines in your
trailer lines trailer I started using
that as short hand we experimented with
other people he dated Ramona I dated
Scott Pilgrim that's why there we go he
went to my high school junior year he
told me the love of his life was waiting
for him back in Canada he also told me
that he liked to live in the moment that
generally meant sloppy makeouts behind
the school yum
yum is it true he punched a hole in the
moon for you teleported to the moon and
absolutely the most romantic thing I've
ever seen the most horrifying thing I've
ever seen oh he did it all for you we
need to talk about Scott Pilgrim I'm
Scott Pilgrim all idiots L's hold that
they're on
method
co-worker no super saiyan vegan at the
end of day two the production was
already $7 million over
budget what's it like working with
Wallace Wells she's taught me so much
about acting no about living what can
you even say about a man like that
no B hold it
eny I can't be with you anymore I'm in
love with Wallace wow wowe I'm a new
person a new
boy my skin is clear it's love things
change when you become Scott any rumors
about me having a very hot onset Affair
or just rumors
I'm here tell him what you just told
me oh boy oh no oh no he's in love with
me isn't
he well Wallace is used to this oh
buddy this was just an onset
fling what when the movie ends so does
the relationship
a what about the Sparks oh what
sparks no
sweetheart oh
no
I like the camera movement a
lot Wallace weld
oh you broke my
boyfriend prepare to
die Ramona like that they acknowledge
the
camera oh that bum stop stop it stop it
if you want to fight with me fight with
them
whoa the stunt doubles why does Wallace
have stunt doubles I don't know time for
stunts wait what I'm doing an interview
do you want to keep your job Ramona
versus The Wallace stunt doubles I like
that nvy Adams is like slightly taller
than Ramona
[Music]
desp I like how this hops in and out of
the
documentary Wells versus Adams Wallace
Wells who said that uh nobody who's the
narrator he's great yeah straight
Wallace you're a stunt double now why
are you acting like that's weird you
made the exact same career chain yes I
did it for very specific reason you got
demoted straight
Wallace oh here we go go Marshall Club
on it Ramona that's the sloppiest
headbutt I've ever seen thought this
supposed to look like a handheld one TI
yeah come
on cool choreography damn yeah whoa
she's like a compa fighter what last
time you hit the gym too many french
fries we can handle physical abuse but
we draw the line and verbal abuse yeah
they're fighting for your honor man
that's not how you motivate they need
positive reinforcement why does your
character want to fight Wallace in the
first place I broke her
boyfriend you and Todd should have put
that together Ramona no more stunts
where is he yeah the handheld motion's
great like it's it feels very authentic
oh Todd fat Thor breaking vegan Edge CH
cheese fries this the first place I made
out with
Wallace this is the second place yep yep
yep blumkin what we had was fun but I've
discovered our new kind of fun would you
care about another
person no no now i''d be chasing that
high for the rest of my life You Can't
Fight The Moonlight
babe no a constellation it's a vegan
portal all right but it's better than
anything Todd's ever made I mean look at
the thought that went into it the
craftsmanship Todd didn't do this it's
like a prime vegan you have no other
leads tragic looks like you're never
going to find him what do you know did
Envy do it she could have done it I
think she might have done it is she a
vegan or a twins I guess I mean env's
the only other vegan we know of right
she is vegan I just assumed yeah and
she's dating Todd might she might
be Matthew Patel
oh with the G belt damn everyone here
works for me right yes sir
good you're all fired why aren't you the
director yes you're
fired Oh no I got wrong you shooting a
documentary or something uh
uhhuh well not anymore hey bab get off
me bab stop no no it was all F I was
enjoying the mockumentary Stu I punched
Scott Pilgrim to death you didn't
actually punch him to death someone
kidnapped him and made it look like you
won I didn't win he's not dead no no
Patel's going to have to go find him is
he mad at me is is he mad at
me the Empire's mind I won't make the
same mistakes he made I won't end up
where he is now which is where exactly
here Toronto he's shacking up with some
girl named Julie something oh did you
know Gideon isn't even his real name
it's Gordon Gordon Goose I guess Gan of
the one who did it Julie it wouldn't be
Julie Powers or did Julie do it Julie
didn't like
Scott I want everybody's food purchases
on my desk maybe it was what they eat
where they big plan to get Gideon back
maybe Julie pow and I need to talk
what do you know
Robo she got the shiny glasses it's not
good hypnotized by the
TV no evil anime
glasses okay it is Kevin McDonald as uh
Edgar wrong next episode starting three
two 1 go oh
yes
that's what I'm talking about what it's
a real anime
now who's this I don't
[Music]
know oh
ouch
taka just watch one of the animes that
inspired this or or like the Studio's
traditional style maybe Goose I'm
looking for Graves Gideon who the hell
is goose you've reached the adult
formally known as gide Graves it's the
goose now Gordon Goose my name isn't
Lucas actually it's
Luke well here's how I see you Goose
I've lost everything you've lost
everything I thought maybe you'd have
some words of advice a I know I left you
in the Lurch after Matthew but if you
could find it in your heart to forgive
me forgiveness is what you want oh he
wants revenge I have something entirely
different in
mind
uhoh looks so much like Billy Butcher
and The
[Music]
[Applause]
Punisher hey hey hey
hey
a
whoa hey
don't get it
twisted it's almost as if letting go of
Ramona Flowers has worked wonders for
everyone but I do keep questioning if I
hadn't seen the movie would I care to
find Scott I mean that's another good
question if this was your first
introduction to all of them you wouldn't
really be any of the wiser would I be
yeah yeah would I care about the
motivation you
[Music]
know indoor house half pipe let's
go oh yeah I was going to say that's not
how you drop
in is that an anime we don't actually
know about it could
be
my I was gone for 90
minutes and what's with the robot what
robot hey hey
that ain't no
Roomba
oh
o got the die the last one didn't have
the die it's because it was a
documentary episode they weren't there
for
this is this just to distinguish the
episodes you know it's her her changing
moods and and her growth through color
who did it who did it Ryan Johnson
episode Julie I'll make this brief is
that the sound of skates eye here tell
to come in here and kick it so it's you
and Gideon now no that's Gordon Gordon
Goose be back in a bit baby okay bye
I'll miss you I'll miss you
more I think the the big end game was to
get him back AUB Plaza diabolical bre
makes
you too obvious bread Makes You
full and how did you get the CEO of Gman
media to bankroll your project Mr Patel
had the capital but he was also an
aspiring Broadway Theater obsessive I
read an interview with him in Forbes yes
sniv an Off Broadway musical and who
better to play the lead than you not a
lot of people know this but I made
majored in theater in college it shows
briefly start in my own onean show let's
see
it
yes Agony misery wo though it's
different for each wow whoever got this
on video got some really great angles
wow
impressive you uh think he's got the
chop
Stephen say yes I've made my decision
Scott Pilgrim's precious little musical
near the go project I got a go picture
hope you know how much we value your
opinion pal we're adapting your work
after all oh I don't I don't care about
the movie shutting down it didn't mean
anything to me I'm just having my own
golf cart Young Neil I don't even
remember writing it uh I dreamed I saw
my sleep paralysis demon at my computer
and I woke up the next day and there it
was who is the demon we have to tell
Ramona about this she's the one who's
been searching for Scott this whole time
really you two moved on with your lives
when we saw Ramona on the movie Set you
were as cool as a cucumber that was
business oh emotional business oh no
emotional
business can I get a
witness stop when I was in high school
in Northway Ontario Gordon Goose was the
weirdest kid in my year his glass
glasses were too big for his face his
clothes fit funny even his hair looked
wrong still got the same shirt yep he
wore those no fear t-shirts every day
one day out of nowhere he presents the
most popular girl in school with a
12-point business plan as to why she
should date him yeah I have no fear of
the sting of rejection therefore there's
no downside to me attempting this damn
this some pretty moving facts and
figures
oh no no I had no idea Gideon Graves was
the dorky kid from my past until he
turned up on my
doorstep made made him into a cool guy
that day Gordon was a Twitchy
rage-filled impulsive emotionally
abusive controlling manipulative
egomaniac hey man he was
rich when Gordon showed up he was power
hungry he wanted Revenge he would have
done anything to get his Empire back but
after a few days it's like the evil
drained out now he just sits on the
couch watching anime all
day maybe none of the other exes were in
on it maybe it was all Gman or maybe the
two of you were in on it together n he's
just a loser trust me you can take him
or us off your list the
twins hey so his real name is Gordon
Goose oh no God damn it Stacy were you e
dropping you shouldn't be here on your
day day off oh scoot scoot on out of
here I was gone for 90 minutes oh nice
little time Loop yeah I said earlier
that morning yeah I just got so caught
up in I
forgot where have I seen that robot she
seems pissed does this mean I can't live
here live here oh no I don't care which
one of you did it you're both going to
pay Julie Bowers versus and Gordon
o stop stop this is stupid what find
your own place I'm flat broke I can't
even afford a first class flight back to
LA and the only work I can get is
voicing an animated series Lucas Le live
action or
nothing how do he lose everything I
don't know that robot where have I seen
it before you know who made him right
that's their special little guy right
there the
twins there you go oh Metal Gear oh good
catch it did say he was like cancelled
after that so maybe they they really
meant it lost everything
yeah my
man oh you son of a [__] show really
captures the sadness to the League what
if I said that while it seemed like I
wasn't doing anything and was throwing a
pity party I was actually planning an
elaborate plan a plan that would turn
Matthew Patel into dust I'd say hot
that's hot yeah yeah oh boy oh boy what
are you all doing here we have
information about your case your Scott
case what if I told you I cracked the
case wide open would any of you want to
hear what I figured out let's compare
info now she's buddies with it everybody
wants they Scot back I've been trying to
figure out who did it why they did it
and how they did it and now I know all
three let's start with the who yes by
now most of you know about my past I've
dated a lot of people who were suspect
that's a similar word to suspects
wow the twins Ken and Kyle katayanagi
they were my Tas in robotics 101
excellent and that leads to the why oh
they have the
motivation okay it was was my second
semester of college I didn't know what I
was doing I was a kid but to the twins I
was fresh
meat they were a couple of players and
they wouldn't leave me alone it's Al
just how creepy dudes can be baked into
the show so maybe I got a little bit of
satisfaction when they figured out I was
playing them right back I was dating
both of them at the same time tabik the
how is a vegan portal but this portal
far exceeded the power level of my only
vegan X what's more powerful than a
human vegan two human vegans a robot
vegan yes of course a robot that's never
eaten
meat a vegan without the inherent flaws
of
humanity created by the
twins dang so every robot can create a
vegan
portal it was at the rocket before sex
went on stage oh it was on the vide
tape I like how the flashbacks on the
videotape or how they were on the show
that even like from the perspective of
the security camera yeah where where is
he we'll know soon enough when I find
the
twins I find Scott boom Young Neil
didn't write that script he didn't write
Scott F precious little life oh no we
didn't figure out the who the why or the
how but we did figure out the when
according to the file data that script
was written 14 years from now
whoa I just got write the script in the
future on a different
timeline you might be
right yeah
Scott hey Scott Where Have You you been
was it the twins are you okay I'm okay
and yes it was the twins okay someone
else was behind the whole thing who me
it was me what I did it Scott how could
you sho dang Scott's a horrible person
yeah [__] Scott
Pilgrim all right all right
dang you know the clothes these guys
wear in the show are
so so fly yeah you think so John they
are some of the flyest but I think I
might have seen flyer clothes maybe once
or twice in my life I would like to buy
their clothes sometimes I like to buy
other YouTubers clothes like Double
Toasted you know I think it's important
to support YouTube channels that you
watch by buying their merch I think it's
important as well just like how John's
wearing the real reject merch right here
who influences the influencers I like
this channel called the real reject and
I wanted to support so I got that's a
real sweet gesture of you to do yeah any
the whole time man real rejects has
shirts that hey could be good Christmas
presents as well the best Christmas
presents like they got this CH
Protection Services one look at that
Pedro and uh baby yod and then you also
got space babies of the Galaxy right
here love those babies we also have the
aoda shirts the aoda and the snip Snips
and and then we got a there's a whole
bunch of that's a bunch of shirts here
dude there's so many and I hear a new
one a Christmas one that's being worked
on it's a kind of a weird one but it's a
Christmas one wow dang you got the
inside track on this stuff I do it's
crazy it's important for me to have
leaking the designs get a hype going out
there early so guys yeah I mean if you
want to just go to like
www.en.com and then um either gift
yourself or gift someone this holiday
season while also showing your support
for real rejects it's a great way to go
about it John what you think of these
episodes oh goodness I mean I wish we
could keep talking about shop reject
nation.com but I guess we'll talk about
the show re.com
reject Nation
shop.com that shop boy can melts
brains seen some of these other intros
people be like what is the shop name and
usually I'm like it's not that hard but
here we are so anyhow reject Nation
shop.com I like these episodes quite a
bit it's you you mentioned at one point
that they're really good at zeroing in
on The
Melancholy with the X's but I think
overall they're kind of good at at
zeroing in on this sort of peripheral
Melancholy that everyone is experiencing
to some degree and so yeah I just
continue to be sort of drawn in and and
fascinated by the atmosphere they have
here because there is like I don't know
it just everything kind of matches the
setting you know you're in kind of a
colder environment anyway there is a
sort of cold that all the characters are
working through um but but yeah I don't
know there's also like kind of a nice
warmth of camaraderie in here and uh
this was quite tumultuous and it makes
sense I guess that at episode 6 we would
at least have like the main mystery
wrapped um but yeah I mean I've loved
you know the the the first episode we
watched with Todd Ingram was just
so so kind of wild um and then the who
did it episode was was more kind of like
focusing in and really getting to the
the meat of things so I think I had a
bit more like outright fun with the
first episode we watched today but uh
I'm enjoying just the grace with which
all of this is unfolding
really yeah yeah I really like the
documentary one a lot um I thought the
way they messed around with their camera
angles on that one just the the energy
the vibe of that one the pacing of it uh
was really to my
liking and uh just the amount of meta
commentary that they were doing on top
of all that as well then anything
playing on like filmmaker mockumentary
sensibilities and something that's just
going to tickle my fancy but even
messing with the relationship with Todd
and envy Adams was a really fun thing to
to dish out you know like one of the
jokes in the movie of the Scott Pilgrim
movie uh with Wallace was like the
amount of action this guy can get and so
to see him like manipulate uh oh God Tod
fall in love with him and how it's like
becoming this destructive part on set
and their relationship uh was a really
joyous experience and then it even led
to a really cool fight scene with uh
Ramona Flowers I thought you know I I
feel like they're not really going to be
doing much with MV uh it seems like
she's the one who's not really I mean
she's not one of Ramona's xes and this
is way more Ramona show right now than
is Scott show Scott will punch her by
the end of the series we'll do that
let's hope so yes so we have that to
deal with and yeah the followup episode
was still very enjoyable it was just
such a high from the mockumentary one
yeah because I even like when you start
off with the rock concert and just like
the amount of jokes that they were made
like I thought it was just a really
funny fun expressive episode and then
the follow-up one I don't know the Julie
character is like she's enjoyable to me
Gideon is he's enjoyable to me I don't
quite love watching them they're like I
said they're they're enjoyable but
they're not they're they're kind of on
the bottom of the list for me yeah in a
way I feel like the impact of Audy
Aubrey Plaza maybe hits a little harder
in the live action because she is able
to like really bring her there's so much
in her expressions and her dead pness
yeah and like I like what she does here
I like the work here and I you know
enjoy the animation of the character and
all that stuff but yeah like I feel like
she in this medium isn't transposed in
as much of a way to like not still feel
like you're dealing with like a bit I
don't know like in the movie she's a
kind of a bit character but like when
you're focused in on her there's still
like a gravity that that she's the
center of the the moments she's in
whereas this feels like she's more of
just like a regular supporting character
who swears a lot yeah and I like Goose's
backstory in the high school that was a
really uh telling flashback that I
it made me care more about him and it
made me find his character significantly
more interesting I liked him and Lucas
Lee together yeah that bond is nice most
yeah of his storyline uh the the part
the part of the show that's semi missing
for me because we're six episodes in and
I and I do think this this part is kind
of missing for me is that pgri is not
even that uh is is that we have and like
I like the ending mystery not there are
a bit of that like Wonder stranger
things Vibes to the mystery unfolding
and you know like there's no rules to
this world uh which I enjoy every
Everything nowadays always like what's
the rules what's the rules so it's kind
of refreshing to watch something that
just Embraces we don't have rules here
yeah or if we do the logic only makes
sense to like somebody yeah per episode
to someone behind the camera and they're
not going to tell you what those rules
are yeah which gives it an an an
anarchic kind of fun spirit that way
yeah yeah so I I enjoy that about this
show but we've spent so much time
getting to know other people and and I
kind of just feel like we our main
character is Ramona and if you're going
to make that choice I want to get to
know Ramona better like we kind of get
to know the characters that she's
talking to like the exes we get to know
each one of the exes we get to know
better and then even like hearing about
the flashbacks yeah and maybe we'll get
that in the last couple of episodes or
maybe the last episode I don't I don't
know um so that is one part of it that
I'm like I do wish that a little bit per
episode we did get to know a little bit
better like sure we've seen her in the
high school and her story of their
stories of falling in love with people
and okay she's got a fighting background
I guess and then she was a little bit
conniving as as a sophomore in in
college sure but you know like it works
the structure of keeping Ramona a
mystery makes so much more sense when
the whole point is you're watching it
from Scott's perspective Ive and he's
uncovering the x's and then it makes the
X's more mysterious and it makes the
game of foot a lot more fun but if
you're making remota the main character
uh you got to do something to make her a
little more interesting yeah we got to
get a bit more personal with her because
it's like all these she's such a dry
personality too yeah and she's such a
motivating factor for so many characters
and like I like her presence in the
moment certainly like her in the- moment
presence but yeah I would agree like
like getting feeling like these episodes
of each brought us a bit more of an
emotional context for Ramona or brought
us closer to her in some way I still
feel about as close or distant as you
know we were kind of from the beginning
from the first episode yeah yeah and and
yeah and that first episode when they're
you know when she and Scott are you know
having those intimate moments together
those are some of the most tender you
get with her and I like that each
episode they take the time to repeat
that ritual of her dying her hair to
suit her you know new moods and Pursuits
and whatever you know it's not the same
as uh spending some additional emotional
time with the character beyond the
physical Motif and I know part of the
humor of and the sensibility of the
Scott Pilgrim world show and movie is
there's no real in between from apathy
to extremity you know and and so she
falls on like everyone of Scott's
friends other than knives Chow you know
every SC like okay you got like young
Neil like super apathetic and then you
have nice CH was like very extreme yeah
and then the drummer very apathetic
totally totally so every character Ste
Stills is very emotional yeah every
character is either apathetic or extreme
right yeah and Ramona would fall under
the apathetic category sure so when this
is like a motivating driving force for
her for some unpronounced reason even to
herself that she doesn't quite
understand you know uh it it loses some
of that drive so when you get a slower
episode like episode six yeah it does
show that it's a slower episode in a way
that I don't entirely find complimentary
sure it makes me
wonder if because I for the most yeah
five I would I would sing its Praises
like all day you know I thought everyone
was great ramono included you know
everyone's great but that's a real
Ensemble thing whereas the six slows
down a lot to focus
on two very apathetic characters yeah
yeah 100% yeah and and then the Gideon
back story was the most interesting part
of it yeah it it makes me wonder if if
that will be an earmark of the binge
because thus far I have felt like most
of these stand pretty I mean you know
they're compact so you want to watch a
bunch of them but they stand pretty
solidly on their own I wonder if that
thread may be one that stands more in
totality like certainly hope and would
expect that the next two episodes hold
some physical and emotional cathares and
and you know developments for Ramona and
so maybe in hindsight those wall
register but I you know in the here and
now I can't deny that you know aspect of
it yeah and then that rests more on the
actual who done it which you know isn't
like which is the mystery but it's not
like an impossible mystery at least
right now because you know especially
when we get to the end of the episode
and it's like well you kind of narrowed
it all down and those are logical kind
of conclusions now the question is why
Scott did all this yeah yeah yeah so you
know I think this episode certainly kind
of leaves you especially if you're going
to take a minute's break with a couple
things that are maybe a little more
questionable than just you know
appreciation as a lot of a lot of the
episodes leave me just like appreciating
various things and then this one yeah
leaves me more contemplating and curious
about again what's going to be ahead
rather than just what I what's here
right now you know yeah yeah cuz I think
the first one of the most appealing
Parts about the first episode to me was
how it's heart and soul and its
Melancholy really saying hi and I think
whenever that's sprinkled in with the
comedy that's when it's working at its
strongest the show yeah is when there is
a genuine sense of
emotionality and um yeah it's not like I
didn't like the the sixth episode I just
thought it was on the weaker side of a
very strong show yeah still strengths in
the episode which is not not the one I
would identify as the strongest yeah
when but when you're like getting close
to the end and it is your who done itep
it is your big like who did it episode I
felt like it should have had a bit more
of an impact I'm curious because again I
again as we've often touched on like I I
out of Eight Episodes I'm curious about
the placement of it as number six for
certain of the functions of this because
we do have two more and often times I
associate like a second to last episode
with like okay here's some emotional and
you know any kind of big physical
resolutions and then next episode we're
going to kind of pay off all of the
themes and then set up for the future so
this is uh I wonder you know if there's
not another big subversion or some other
kind of shoe to drop or surprise to come
and maybe they're luring us into like a
false sense of like okay well we know
most of what happened and now we just
got to wrap it all up you know maybe
there's something else here we'll see
guys what did you think the episode
leave your thoughts down below uh be
sure to subscribe leave a like and hey
let's send us with a patron the day
shout out Gabriel we're thankful for you
today you're getting a solo shout out
one of the rare ones this month as
there's time you better be thankful
Gabriel for this I assume you're in
these United States even though you're
no angel you are a benevolent kind
person who has been here supporting us
for far too long for far too long
especially when we you know made all
those tacky Angel Gabriel jokes that I
now regret and we'll never ever
reference we were hoping we could
pressure you we were hoping we could but
you know you didn't need pressured you
stuck around you know we don't follow
religion but we thought it' be funny if
we can convert you yeah exactly we we
care about your soul here at the patreon
we want you to be with us during the
Rapture as we Ascend in God's CED hands
you know to Valhalla and we don't want
you to slip through like you know the
waters tyranny and idle uh handedness uh
Gabriel we want you to be
exalted at our side blessed uh by the
host of of the Heavenly uh you know
promise that Jesus has left for us this
is our way of saying thank you thank you
Gabriel on this Thanksgiving month yes
if you open your Bible to any any of the
gospels Jesus had a dinner with his
friends you could pretend like you're
having worst thing you could have done
Gabriel is is after us making a bunch of
jokes about angel [__] is then come back
and tell us you're an atheist cuz then
we're just going to double down yep yep
yep these are going to be the most Pious
by now you you should have known that
this probably the directory would have
gone next month's shout out we're just
going to say the rosary for like 40s
through the whole thing you know how
many get we're going live stream of mass
yes we're going to rent the local church
out we're going to invite people and
it's all going to be in your honor you
know so I hope you appreciate I hope you
too if you don't tune in live it's going
to be really embarrassing man but uh in
all seriousness thank you for being here
for so long it's been a very long time
you've been here man and uh thank you
for not wavering yeah we love you and I
hope to keep you around uh definitely
for sure definitely if you uh go to
heaven with us so uh thank you for being
you and looking forward to coming up
with something non-religious next month
for you lift up your
hearts we'll deliver you from evil
Gabriel